Closing out
the year with a
huge accolade,
the pop star
superstar one Time magazine's 20
person of the year
this month
because according to Time quote
no one else on the planet
today can move so many people so
Achieving
this feat is something we often
to the alignments of planets
and faith for giving too much cr
to the stars ignores her skill
and her power.
Swift Eras
tour grossed
$2.2 billion in North American t
sales alone.
And our concert films
opening weekend
raked in $96 million at the box
in the US and Canada.
That is the highest grossing con
film domestically ever
for an opening weekend.
And it's worth pointing out
she's not alone in helping
boost the US economy this year.
She joins a list of powerful wom
making significant contributions
include, of course,
Beyonce,
a documentary about her record
breaking world
tour renaissance
topped the box office
earlier this month
with $21 million in its opening
And this summer's Greta Gerwig's
Barbie became
the highest grossing movie of 20
That was back in August
with a domestic
haul of over $570 million at the
Joining us now CNN economic
commentator and Washington Post
columnist Catherine
Rampell and CNN business
correspondent Rachel Solomon.
Thank you thank you for for bein
Let me start with you. What a ye
Obviously, Taylor Swift, Beyonce
so many other women
boosting this economy.
Yeah.
I mean, really boosting
consumer spending.
At a time
when we thought that consumer sp
would actually start to fall.
So what you have to understand,
you did a good job going over
some of the numbers.
There is
these women have monumental fanb
and these women
and the men who support them
are spending a lot of money.
Colorado, for its part,
said that it expected
Taylor Swift in her
tour to pump $140 million
into the Colorado GDP On average
they expected the average Swift
who was attending
to spend about 1300 dollars.
And what you have to remember
is we're not just talking
Garrison, Garrison Amazon
that's more than rent
for so many times over.
Not in New York, but yes, for su
But what you have to remember
is we're not just talking
about the ticket sales,
but we're talking about the flig
to perhaps
get to Denver, Colorado,
or to Philadelphia.
The Philadelphia Fed, by the way
has talked about Taylor Swift
and the impact on the hotel occu
Also, the apparel.
I mean, you got to look once
you go to see these ladies in co
So they are huge, monumental bus
of this.
Catherine, to that point,
it felt like at various points
of the year,
even economists would say these
or three
extraordinary women were lifting
the economies of various places
on their own.
Is that an overstatement
or is that actually close to acc
I think at least in the near ter
yeah,
it had a big impact on local eco
as realtors just pointed out.
It meant
higher sales for hotels for exam
lots of other kinds of local spe
any other kind of hospitality,
restaurants, local transit,
that sort of thing.
So, yeah, these amazing women
not only generated
likely billions of dollars for t
and for the people who worked
on their respective tours
or other kinds of artistic proje
but also had some knock on effec
for the local economies that wer
them were even countries
I was just looking at up.
Remember when we were talking ab
I think it was Sweden
and Beyonce may be right around.
Remember Beyonce
blaming Beyonce for the inflatio
Yeah. Come on, come on, come on.
You had a really interesting pie
Kathryn, about the she covery.
20, 23.
Yes.
So 2023 was the
year of
the working woman,
not just famous women
like the ones we've been talking
but regular
rank and file
white collar
women around the United States
whose numbers have hit record hi
in terms of the share
of traditionally working age
people who are employed.
You may remember that
a couple of years ago
there were all of these stories
about the fear of the shit sessi
that the pandemic
was disproportionately
going to hurt women
and did seem to hurt women,
particularly those
who had young children,
and that they might be knocked o
their career trajectories for,
if not forever, for a very long
that there would be
these scarring effects.
Instead, the exact opposite has
Women, working women have come b
with a fierce,
almost like revengeful loss,
a level of success
that they are contributing finan
to their households.
They are somehow managing to mak
and family commitments work out.
And I don't know if I would go s
as to say
women are finally having it all,
but they are really punching
above their weight.
If we manage to avoid a recessio
year, as many had feared
not too long ago,
it will be because of America's
working women again
powering this economy,
where, you know, we're
held to that point.
Is this can this be maintained?
I know
Taylor Swift
and Beyonce are touring for like
and I have no idea
how they're doing that.
They're absolute machines.
But their success,
the success of the Academy
is just talking about
can this hold over
a longer period of time.
You know,
it's an interesting point,
I think, at least for the time b
because now you think about
at least Beyonce
having the documentary and movie
which is boosting
sort of movie ticket sales. Righ
So I think certainly as long as
are offering
a product, Beyonce is also now
selling perfume, right.
In addition
to her production company,
in addition to her Ivy Park line
I mean, there is always a way
you can sort of cash
in on being a Beyonce fan.
And I assume the same with Taylo
How have I made it through this
going to neither of those
especially when you know that
I've been to the Beyonce
concert multiple times
the film,
you still have time, best husban
when she's on tour for.
Yeah, she's on tour.
Reminder, Phil Surprises
Wife in Paris
at Beyonce, Babe in Paris, honey
my husband. Isn't that amazing?
Yeah. No, it's amazing.
Okay, we got to go.
Thank you very much for this alb
I guess the ramp up.